[Aplausos]
alguna vez sufrieron un corte de agua
levantemos la mano los que sufrimos un
corte de agua
todo es verdad
esta sucede sólo vivimos hace poco hace
poco más de un año y medio cuando lima y
varios departamentos del perú se
quedaron por lo menos una semana sin
agua
fue como una odisea la odisea del agua
en este entonces todos entramos en un
estado zombie
todos y no precisamente a barra está
vamos los supermercados para ir en busca
de cerebro sin morder los sino por una
botella de agua
era increíble esta situación ya qué
pronto
todos
encontraban las botellas en los
supermercados y cogían las que podían
hasta que quedó la última botella
pero esta situación no terminó ahí los
camiones-cisterna nos ayudaron a poder
abastecernos de agua empezaron a
recorrer toda la ciudad para que
suministren a las familias que
necesitaban mucho del agua
sin embargo
en la ciudad
esto no sabes decir
algunas personas que vivían cerca de las
riberas del mar utilizaban el agua el
mar para diferentes usos pero otras que
no tenían esta posibilidad en los en en
el centro de lima porque los que vivían
por los parques utilizaban el agua
incluso de las piletas
recordábamos todos ese momento
una verdadera odisea
felizmente
este problema se fue solucionando
paulatinamente
y la mayoría empezó a tener agua en sus
casas
sin embargo el día de hoy sábado 20 de
octubre hay 30 millones de peruanos que
están viviendo este aumento que siguen
viviendo la odisea del agua 30 millones
de peruanos
3 millones de peruanos disculpen
21 millones de personas en latinoamérica
que vive en esta situación y 500
millones de personas en el mundo que
están pasando por estas circunstancias
por las circunstancias que nosotros
pasamos en ese entonces
pero
esta situación
es
es muy grave
es muy grave porque
las personas para encontrar agua tienen
que invertir demasiado esfuerzo caminar
algunas obras en algunos casos y el agua
que obtiene también les cuesta mucho es
la más cara que pueden conseguir
y si tienen una fuente de agua que
consiguen la que consiguen está
contaminada
pero hay algo más alarmante según esta
proyección desde el año 2040
el perú
se quedará sin agua
sufriremos un alto estrés hídrico del
agua esto quiere decir de que la
cantidad
de agua que tengamos disponible en este
momento
no será suficiente para abastecer a
todas las personas que habitan en este
entonces
perú chile méxico cuba serán los países
más afectados
en este año no solo enfrentaremos estos
problemas el mundo enfrentará más
problemas problemas como la falta de
alimentos como las enfermedades
innumerables problemas
pero
donde podemos encontrar las soluciones
como podemos hacer para encontrar las
respuestas a estos problemas gravitantes
que tenemos ya los que nos vamos a
enfrentar
algunos le tienen mucha fe a los
extraterrestres
pero este problema nos toca resolverlo a
nosotros a los seres humanos
existe un portal justo en este momento
al qué
podemos acceder
este portal está aquí ese portal en el
que podemos encontrar todas las
soluciones todas las respuestas a los
problemas
que tenemos ya los que nos vamos a
enfrentar sin embargo
cada vez nos hemos alejado de este
portal
este portal en el que podemos encontrar
todas las respuestas se llama
la naturaleza
en la naturaleza se encuentran todas las
respuestas a los problemas que tenemos
absolutamente a todos los problemas
voy a mostrarles mediante un ejemplo
cómo podemos encontrar
la solución al problema del agua
la solución al problema del agua se
encuentra
en mayor medida en un insecto
podemos encontrar la solución al
problema del agua en un insecto
este insecto vive en el desierto
pero tiene una peculiaridad como podrán
ver está empapado del agua
el insecto está empapado de agua y no es
que alguien haya agarrado una botella y
le haya regalado en efecto
este insecto tiene un mecanismo
interesante que le permite adquirir agua
en el desierto
a través de la cubierta que posee tiene
una membrana una especie de red de micro
red que le permite condensar el agua de
las mañanas en el amanecer sube a las
dunas de los desiertos se posa ahí
puede obtener el agua por condensación
qué pasaría si nosotros invitaremos este
mecanismo para obtener agua en la costa
qué pasaría
si miráramos este mecanismo creen que
funcionaría
creen que funcionaría un mecanismo
basado en este insecto para obtener agua
claro que sí funcionaría porque este
mecanismo ya funciona hace miles de años
y está presente ahí con el insecto
si funcionaría y nos ayudaría a obtener
agua en el desierto
pero no es el único ser maravilloso que
se encuentra
también encontramos esta planta que
también vive en el desierto
pero tiene la particularidad de captar
de forma eficiente el agua de la lluvia
mira la disposición de las hojas que
tiene
tiene una estructura increíble que le
permite
capturar la mayor cantidad de agua de la
lluvia y re dirigirla hacia el centro de
esta forma la aprovecha y a diferencia
de otras plantas del desierto
se abastece de agua y puede florecer
pero la naturaleza nos sigue
sorprendiendo aún más
este es un caracol
no sólo sirve para hacer sopa de caracol
como dice la canción
sino también nos brinda una geometría
espectacular nos puede ayudar a
condensar agua a partir de la humedad
del aire
en este ambiente tenemos humedad
según los cálculos que dice hoy
aproximadamente 18 gramos de humedad por
metro cúbico de ahí
podríamos nosotros obtener el agua que
se encuentra en este ambiente gracias a
esta geometría de este caracol si
nosotros pasamos aire por la parte
superior el aire que obtendremos en la
parte inferior del caracol será aire más
frío esto nos permite llegar al punto de
condensación del agua
y lo que hicimos nosotros fue
básicamente es imitar estos mecanismos
de la naturaleza para generar un sistema
multifuncional
en el centro imitamos el mecanismo
del insecto
las palas asemejan a una turbina eólica
pero también le dan la capacidad de
capturar el agua de la lluvia hacia el
centro como la planta del desierto
y un sistema de condensación interno que
imita el sistema del carbón
esto se puede aplicar en la costa para
condensar el agua de la neblina en la
selva para capturar el agua de la lluvia
y también en la sierra
con un sistema de enfriamiento que está
basado en energías renovables
en un sistema práctico seguro y que nos
brinda agua
agua para los 3 millones de peruanos
y todas las personas en latinoamérica y
en el mundo que necesitan de este
recurso
actualmente estamos beneficiando a
colegios
que no tienen agua
y también vamos a escalar a clínicas
las comunidades que aún no cuentan con
este recurso
estamos llevando agua gracias
a la naturaleza a que hemos imitado el
mecanismo de la naturaleza para generar
este sistema que nos va a permitir
obtener el recurso más importante
del que todos dependemos
pero la naturaleza
es sabia y nos sigue enseñando mucho más
y hemos podido resolver un problema
tecnológico ambiental
pero
nos puede enseñar incluso a resolver los
problemas de nuestra vida cotidiana
la naturaleza
nos puede enseñar por ejemplo el camino
al éxito
existen muchos libros que se escribieron
acerca del camino al éxito
infinidad de libros miles de libros pero
las respuestas están en una planta en
una maceta
quienes tienen una maceta
pues esta maceta
nos ilustra perfectamente cuál es el
camino hacia el éxito está siempre con
nosotros en nuestras casas pero pasa
desapercibida
para que esta planta crezca primero fue
una semilla
una semilla que estuvo que enterrarse
a lo que nosotros le llamamos tocar
fondo
seguramente muchos estamos tocando fondo
luego esta semilla empezó a tener raíces
a lo que nosotros le llamamos expandir
nuestras ideas reflexionar pensar
meditar
luego
esta semilla empezará a salir de su zona
de confort al igual que nosotros
saldremos de nuestra zona de confort
pero esto no terminará ahí
esta planta
enfrentar a diferentes dificultades
lluvia
radiación
pero estas dificultades
le permiten crecer
si bien la lluvia es intensa a veces
para esta planta
también es benéfica porque le brinda el
agua
y también la radiación le permite crecer
y nosotros también nosotros enfrentamos
diferentes problemas adversidades que
muchas veces nos tumban pero éstas no
nos permiten crecer
luego de todo este proceso finalmente
esta planta
flores
y nosotros también podemos alcanzar
nuestros sueños nuestros objetivos vivir
en un mundo mejor
mira profundamente en la naturaleza y
entenderás todo mejor albert 6 muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]